- courage when he was lorry Ashbourne
and I'm so happy to be sharing this
video with you I found out about you
guys - stage 32 which is a fantastic
resource and I love your content and I
love your name it takes a lot of courage
to be in this industry and you know
fortune favors the brave so I'm hoping
to jump on your family and I've been in
the industry for a while
focused on screenwriting for probably
about eight years now
I was with Disney for a very long time
and we used to pitch projects regularly
at something called the gong show and
this project that I had now I did not do
there true story because before Johnny
Depp came onto the scene there I pitched
a pirate movie I pitched Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory remake I pitched
The Invisible Man
none of which they picked up for me
but we all know that they eventually did
make them thankfully I held on to this
one knowing that I wanted it for myself
and I recently dusted it off it's called
the last favorite and it's based on the
formative years of Cleopatra's life
something that's never been focused on
film before it's her as a teenager so
there's none of that you know sleazing
love interest stuff but it exemplifies a
an interesting female character in a
male-dominated society and the timing is
right it's done very well in some
competitions it's gotten a lot of
requests for reads at studios and
whatnot it's being evaluated in a couple
of places and depending on
those evaluations go whether it pans out
or not I may end up producing it myself
I have some great resources that are
coming out this year that will enable a
studio quality animated film to be
produced at a fraction of the cost of a
studio because of the overhead involved
so you know if things worked out and
they and they end up going that work
myself and I'm perfectly able to do so
based on my connections and this new
technology so we'll see what happens in
that regard in my daily life I do a lot
of coverage and judging for competitions
and producing as well so I spend about
half my day doing to other people's
projects and we have a half during my
projects and this is one of them in
screenwriting I have found my metaphor
for life if you will if you think of it
as the traditional character arc I would
probably be approaching my midpoint
maybe not quite there yet but anyway I'm
but going up for the fun ride and I look
forward to talking to you more and I
appreciate your time